CHILDREN AND YOUNG AADULTSES.
NEIL?
>> Neil: THANKS, MATT.
I WANT TO GO TO JIM SKINNER, THE
COLLIN COUNTY TEXAS SHERIFF.
SHERIFF, THE DRUG ELEMENT HOFF
FENTANYL AND EVERYTHING ELSE
SEEMS TO COMPOUND THE TENSIONS
AND THE CRISIS BUILDING.
HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY ASSURANCES
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION, AT
LEAST THAT PART OF IT, THE
THREAT, THE REAL DRUG THREAT TO
AMERICANS THAT THEY'RE WILLING
AND READY TO RESPOND TO?
>> NEIL, YOU CAN'T EVEN GET A
MEETING WITH THESE GUYS.
SHERIFFS IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO MEET WITH THE
PRESIDENT 1 1/2 YEARS AND ALL WE
HEAR IS CRICKETS.
ANY SHERIFF WILL TELL YOU THE
SITUATION HERE ON THE CERTAIN
BORDER IS AN UNMITIGATED
DISASTER.
THE DRUGS TRAFFICKED BY THE
CARTELS ARE A TSUNAMI OF DEATH
CRASHING IN THE UNITED STATES
ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT'S AN EPIC SLAUGHTER OF
AMERICANS TAKING PLACE.
THE MURDER WEAPON IS FENTANYL.
THE DRUG CARTELS ARE PUSHING IN
TO ABSOLUTELY EVERY COMMUNITY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
I'M LOCATED IN
DALLAS-FORT WORTH.
THE SECOND FASTEST GROWING
COUNTY IN THE UNITED STATES
BEHIND MARICOPA COUNTY IN
ARIZONA.
WE'VE HAD 571% INCREASE IN
FENTANYL-RELATED DEATHS SINCE
2019.
WHEREVER YOU ARE WATCHING THIS
PROGRAM, IF YOU GET YOUR NUMBERS
THERE, YOU'LL FIND A SIMILAR
TREND OR WORSE.
SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, THIS IS
JUST AN ABSOLUTE UTTER COLOSSAL
FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP IN
WASHINGTON.
>> Neil: YOU CALLED IT A TSUNAMI
OF DEATH.
I KNOW THAT THE HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY, MAYORKAS,
WAS IN YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE HAVOC THAT
IS BEING WREAKED THERE.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE TEXAS
GOVERNOR, GREG ABBOTT AND HIS
POLICY OF BUSSING MIGRANTS OR
THOSE CAUGHT AT THE BORDER TO
CITIES LIKE WASHINGTON AND
NEW YORK.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> THIS IS A GREAT POINT.
RIGHT?
HE'S MAKING THE POINT FOR US IN
THAT HIS PRIORITIES ARE
ABSOLUTELY BACKWARDS.
NEW YORKERS ARE GREAT PEOPLE.
WE CAN'T THANK THEM ENOUGH FOR
TAKING SOME OF THE PRESSURE OFF
OF THESE CITIES ALONG THE BORDER
THAT ARE INUNDATED.
THE REALITY IS, YOU HAVE THE
MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY AND
WASHINGTON D.C. COMPLAINING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE INSTEAD OF
TALKING ABOUT THE REAL PROBLEM,
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THESE DRUG
CARTELS THAT ARE PUSHING THIS
FENTANYL ACROSS, MURDERING
AMERICANS.
HOW MANY OF THEIR FOLKS IN NEW
YORK CITY AND WASHINGTON HAVE
PERISHED BY FENTANYL?
WHY AREN'T THEY ASKING WHAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION DOING?
WHAT IS THE TRIP WIRE?
WHAT IS IT GOING TO TAKE FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION TO GET WITH
THE PROGRAM AND START PUTTING IT
TOGETHER?
WE'VE GOT SUGGESTIONS IF YOU
GUYS WILL BOTHER TO MEET WITH
US.
>> Neil: AND THEY STILL HAVEN'T.
>> UNFORTUNATELY NOT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THESE
ISSUES, YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF
WHEN YOU'VE SEEN AS MANY DEATHS
AS WE'VE SEEN, THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY TALKED ABOUT TOUGHER
SENTENCES FOR PEOPLE DEALING
FENTANYL.
THAT'S A GREAT START.
YOU HAVE TO DO BETTER THAN THAT.
WHERE ARE THE COMMERCIALS ON
TELEVISION EVERY NIGHT AND
SOCIAL MEDIA CAMPAIGNS WARNING
PARENTS AND YOUNG PEOPLE ABOUT
THE DANGERS OF THESE KNOCK-OFF
PRESCRIPTION PILLS THAT ARE
EMBEDDED -- IMPREGNATED WITH
FENTANYL?
WHAT ABOUT FUNDING THE CRIME
ANALYSTS AND THE BADLY-NEEDED
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE NEED IN ORDER
TO COMBAT THESE DRUG
TRAFFICKERS?
HERE IN NORTH TEXAS, I'VE TEAMED
UP WITH SEVEN OTHER SHERIFFS.
WE'VE SEIZED TONS OF NARCOTICS
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF CARTEL
BULK CASH MONEY.
LISTEN, THE GOVERNMENT OUGHT TO
BE HEING SHERIFFS ACROSS THIS
ENTIRE COUNTRY BECAUSE WE ALL
HAVE IN COMMON LONG DISTANCES OF
OPEN ROAD.
WHEN THEY MOVE IN THIS COUNTRY,
THEY HAVE TO MOVE ACROSS THE
OPEN ROAD.
WHY ISN'T THE ADMINISTRATION
HELPING SHERIFFS COME UP WITH
CRIMINAL INTERDICTION UNITS TO
COMBAT THESE TRAFFICKERS?
>> Neil: SHERIFF, POWERFUL
STUF